so congrats on the film I got to see it
last night and as we were just talking
about it's supremely emotional so you
know what was your feeling after see I'm
assuming you were there like how how was
it seeing it with a crowd with an
audience like I hadn't seen the final
product so to see it in a kind of
auditorium with I don't know I think it
was like a thousand people or something
there's so overwhelming and at the end
you know we had a special guest in the
room which was the real chef
Hemant Oberoi one of the survivors of
the attack and he got a standing ovation
everyone was on their feet for him and
it was very very emotional yeah yeah so
I know that the tenth anniversary of
this horrible event is coming up but
aside from that why do you think that
this is a film that the world needs now
I think then they need it now because it
you know it's kind of this this
undercurrent in the news everywhere you
know we're fed this word terrorism
terrorism this that and it's it's kiss
it's spoken so much about but it's also
so elusive that you don't really
understand anything about it or and this
film does a wonderful thing of really
painting the shades of grey sometimes of
these characters say in a way you look
at some of these young radicalized boys
from the outskirts of regions like
Pakistan that have no money and no food
and you and you can you can't understand
you can't agree with what they did but
you can understand how they got
radicalized you know and that's very
interesting
and you can also it what it does is it
really unifies people and and when
you're in this small hotel with all
these different people of different
religions and colors and you when that
when the terrorists come in there is no
rich or poor you know black or white
we're all just humans at the end of the
day and it kind of is a very unifying
feeling absolutely and I think what you
just touched on and the film does a
really amazing job of sort of breaking
down those barriers there's a very
beautiful moment in the film
you and the older hotel guests where
instead of you instead of your character
sort of shying away from you know her
her prejudice you go and explain it to
her and it solves the problem so can you
talk about that moment a little bit like
and I feel like there were a couple of
those in the film was that a decision
that you in the director made was part
of the story
well I it's kind of interesting I met
Anthony and I wasn't signed on to the
film and it was meant to be like a
discussion to see whether I'm interested
or whatnot and it became this Goliath
seven our script session all of a sudden
and was sitting on this rooftop painting
you know coffees and and I was like you
know I just need I need another angle to
this guy to really sink my teeth into
and I'd read these articles about these
sea cab drivers you know being attacked
after 9/11 and it broke my heart you
know you know people were calling them
all sorts of names and terrorists and
and one of the men was like uh I'm Sikh
I come at like I you know it totally got
me wrong in every way you know and it
was fascinating to me that and I thought
this would be great when you're in this
pressure cooker of these four walls of
this hotel you know you have a man with
this big beard in this turban and to the
uncultured I he can look very
intimidating and what a better way then
to break down these cultural prejudices
and with our art and there's a scene in
there where he explains to a woman how
precious this turban is and it's
actually to do with helping others and
and being a warrior and looking after
people around him and being Noble and he
pulls out his phone which was the scene
that we worked on with the writer and he
just showed this woman who thought you
suiza terrorists his young child and
- II said look
my family
and I'm basically
it's like you in a different package
yeah I thought it was um really
a really nice beautiful moment and I I
do sir
I think it made it all the more
heartbreaking
later on when he does have to take
yeah yeah soy
you know we talked to you guys on the
carpet last night
like this whole cast felt like a family
you guys were very much in it together
and it was a very difficult film to make
I want to know how you sort of like
decompress
or slick even last night how did you
like how do you sort of just kind of
are you able to leave it or
um we're already
nicely
one we all had a little cry
to backstage is the truth that sounds
really deep
Rosie you know an open carry
in Astana over 500 movies was there any
I've seen Mumbai you know it's a big
Bollywood song
well and he just
first it and and he's to see tend to me
one bro
Thunder on stage it is turn
I think it can't stop crying should I
walk
I might know this day it's fine it's
fine
and you've got this but it mental
so it means a lot for everyone but
especially
Ahlan like him and we know with that
that's as a family after work because
you
potentially in a mock terrorist
situation for three months
if so
while there's lots of dinners and my
I mean and laughing afterwards
to get through it amazing thank you so
much Congrats on the film thank you very
much